[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
du à 7,8 débat vingt ans après la haine
rien ou presque n'a changé en banlieue
c'est le constat du réalisateur
franciliens ladj ly dans son premier
film les misérables en salles ce
mercredi à 20 novembre
une oeuvre qui interroge sur les
rapports entre jeunes et police sur les
tensions sociales aussi que peuvent qui
peuvent conduire au phénomène des
violences urbaines dernier incident
notable dans le département lincendie du
chapiteau de l'archet début novembre à
chanteloup les vignes
comment expliquer ces violences qui en
est responsable et surtout comment les
endiguer c'est le débat du mois et pour
parler du sujet julien lecat mon soir en
soie secrétaire régional d'alliance
police nationale 78 et bonsoir mohamed
khamlichi soir président du comité de
quartier des merisiers attrape persie à
tous les deux d'avoir répondu
favorablement à notre invitation je
précise que malgré de nombreuses
sollicitations de des maires des
communes qui sont concernées par ces
violences
aucun n'a pu se rendre ce soir en
plateau rappelons qu'en ce moment il ya
le congrès des maires de france et ça
peut expliquer effectivement certaines
défections messieurs pour débuter cette
émission je vous propose d'écouter tout
de suite le sociologue fabien jobard du
centre de recherches sociologiques sur
le droit et les institutions pénales
c'est un laboratoire qui est basé à
guyancourt
il nous parle justement du phénomène des
violences urbaines un phénomène qui
n'est pas nouveau
selon lui écouter il ya quelque chose
qui caractérise la france sur ces
questions là c'est effectivement la
récurrence des violences urbaines
si vous prenez un pays comme
l'angleterre par exemple c'était un
problème très fort à la fin des années
70 au début des années 80 et
le gouvernement anglais un choisi de
s'attaquer à l'une des sources du
problème qui est la tension qui existe
entre jeunes et police c'est pas le seul
élément explicatif mais c'est un des
éléments qui expliquent que dans les
années 90 les années 2000 la situation
était beaucoup plus calme en angleterre
qu'elle ne l'a été en france ou au
contraire des années 90 et 2000
c'est un reparti en flèche un phénomène
donc récurrente ces violences urbaines
qui existe toujours aujourd'hui on pense
forcément aux années 1990 à l'année 2005
année des émeutes en banlieue suite à la
mort des jeunes zyed et bouna
depuis que vous êtes policier julien le
cam est ce que ces violences elles ont
toujours existé ou au contraire elles se
sont sont en hausse depuis ces dernières
années
quel est votre constat alors sur
département ce phénomène est en
véritable explosion là depuis l'été
dernier on a vu des évènements sur saint
germain en laye avec notamment des
incidents à la fête des loges
on a eu après des événements à
sartrouville plaisir les mureaux
également à trappes et l'a dernièrement
mantes-la-jolie et champions donc
malheureusement le département et et on
va dire habitués habitué à ce phénomène
même s'il est en forte augmentation ces
derniers mois mais le reconnaît les
événements qui a eu lieu à trappes en
2013 chanteloup les vignes
on a eu également en 2006 donc le
département est un département touché
par les violences urbaines en depuis le
début de l'année les violences à
l'encontre des personnes dépositaires de
l'autorité publique ont augmenté de 14%
je précise que ce chiffre n'englobe pas
les seules violences commises dans les
quartiers c'est un chiffre plus global
qui englobe notamment les violences lors
des manifestations des défilés jaune le
moral des troupes
il est au plus bas aujourd'hui tout à
fait on peut le voir dans le 2 octobre
dernier vous aviez 27 mille policiers
sur paris pour manifester leur
mécontentement
le département des yvelines est
fortement touchée par ce cette grogne
il faut savoir que les
les services du département sont au bord
de l'implosion on peut parler comme ça
et c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs qu'une
qu'une action est prévue le 5 décembre
prochain avec une journée où on invite à
fermer les commissariats sur le
département
mohamed kabylie les violences notamment
entre quartiers ont été une réalité à
trappes ces dernières années on pense
forcément à la mort du jeune moussa en
2015 tué par balle victimes collatérales
sans doute une rivalité de deux
quartiers sous fond de trafic de
stupéfiants
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que la
situation s'enlise est ce que le constat
est est négatif notre côté non sur
trappe la situation s'est nettement fait
amélioré on a pu cette rivalité
puisqu'ils ont conclu à un accord fin
d'un core c'est à dire qu'ils ont stoppé
les rivalités entre les deux quartiers
mais c'était un long travail puisque
c'est laisser les grandes du quartier de
quartier puis des autres de la ville qui
ont bénéficié qui ont permis cette
réconciliation
en tout cas qui était bénéfique pour
l'ensemble des citoyens
les premiers qui pâtissent de cette
situation c'est les citoyens mdc des
violences précisons le tout de suite un
qui sont l'oeuvre d'une minorité ça ne
concerne pas la majorité du quartier
mais justement cette minorité
l'oeuvre de cette minorité les les
violences qu'elles commettent est ce que
ça nuit justement à la réputation des
quartiers ça donne une mauvaise image
des cas réglés sur bien sûr mais après
c'est un travail de longue haleine dans
cette réputation a changé à modifier et
comme on en voit pour les gilet jaune
comme on voit dans la difficulté dans
nos quartiers sensibles
c'est que la violence ou l'expression ne
se manifeste que par la violence il n'y
a pas d'autres moyens d'expression
les gilets jaunes ont trouvé le moyen de
revendiquer dans la rue
dans les quartiers populaires et
quartiers sensibles à cette
manifestation va se trouver
immédiatement par de la violence de la
casse ce qui est dommage on cautionnait
absolument pas mais c'est c'est en tout
cas un une progression et une
accumulation de questions ou de réponses
auxquelles les habitants n'ont pas honte
des questions maison pas de réponse donc
un moment donné ça découle forcément à
de la violence de leur part parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de moyens d'expression et oui
il ya des structures qui seraient mises
en place pour essayer d'endiguer ces
phénomènes les structures
pas vraiment il n'ya pas vraiment de
structures qui essaye d endiguer ce
phénomène là il n'y a pas de on le voit
aujourd'hui dans les quartiers suivi
pleinement je suis président d'un comité
de quartier nous on nous restreint notre
activité en lien vers ce public au en
lien avec la police pour éviter de ces
affrontements est en tout cas au moins
il ya un minimum qui a une entente une
écoute un premier rapprochement etc qui
pourraient être bénéfiques un pur
portement et la police et les
populations sinon derrière nous nous
refuse de mettre en place les
dispositifs là on a les mains liées et
donc le phénomène continue et perdure
vous verrez ce que c'est vrai qu'il n'a
pas de dialogues forcément pour endiguer
ce phénomène
au sein des quartiers chics avec les
associations en tout cas c'est limité
parce que nous le département il manque
quasiment 300 fonctionnaires sur le
département sur l'agglomération
d'elancourt traduit en cour
on dénombre peu près une quarantaine de
fonctionnaires en moins donc pour
effectivement établir des brigades qui
prendrait contact avec les jeunes ça ça
coûte énormément un effectif mais vous
n'avez pu cette possibilité on peut
constater en début des années 2000 qui
avait la mise en place et l'ouverture
des différents bureaux de police sur le
département
tous les bureaux de police ont été
fermés donc il ya des commissariats qui
ont été fermés donc ces unités qui à la
base avait une proximité avec peut-être
des jeunes de quartiers on a pu ces
unités
maintenant vous avez même du mal assurée
déjà les missions de police secours sur
le département
et c'est dès missions que vous ne pouvez
plus faire faute d'effectifs on parlera
tout à l'heure du manque d'effectif le
cas des violences justement contre les
policiers j'inclus aussi les pompiers
qui sont victimes de violences ces
derniers mois qui sont pris dans de
véritables guets-apens comment on peut
les expliquer alors est ce que on peut
mettre sur la table la question des
réseaux sociaux il ya des quartiers qui
se lancent des défis au travers des
réseaux sociaux est ce que ça se fait
augmenter le jeune qui a un effet de
mimétisme vous avez je pense les réseaux
sociaux vont participer au phénomène où
les individus vont se côtoyer
je le procédé de mantes-la-jolie l'aller
était au pied à chanteloup les vignes
c'est le même principe les individus
brûle une poubelle attire l'intervention
des pompiers prépare un véritable
guet-apens il faut savoir que cdd
guet-apens qui sont préparés des tas de
cailloux sont préparer des cocktails
molotov des feux d'artifice ont lancé
dès l'arrivée des forces de l'ordre et
s'est par contre il ya un vrai phénomène
de copies après de là à ce que c'est les
réseaux sociaux pour moi ne sont pas à
l'origine quand même de ces violences
urbaines route qui vous dit être sur le
terrain avec tes amis comment vous vous
les expliquez vous ces phénomènes de
violence justement son inexplicable en
c'est de la bêtise humaine pure et
simple
je vois pas comment un citoyen peut
s'attaquer un pompier qui est là pour
faire du bien la population et secourir
des populations et des vies humaines
donc je sais pure et simplement de la
bêtise humaine est ce que sa part
galérait sociaux vous faire lui que
copier coller la ville d'à côté je sais
pas mais en tout cas c'est sûr il va
falloir un moment donné m mettre les
pieds dans le plat et comprendre
pourquoi pourquoi ils réagissent comme
ça etc mais c'est vrai que ça demande
des moyens ça demande énormément de
moyens nous sur le territoire on n'a pas
de moyens
c'est pour ça que on a toujours dit en
tout cas moi je suis toujours le premier
à prôner la discussion autour d'une
table et tables rondes entre les
différents acteurs mais aussi que le
politique met le pied dans le plat c'est
aux politiques de d'impulser une
dynamique 6,6 dans nos municipalités on
n'a pas cette volonté de calmer les
tensions de calmer les jeunes dans les
quartiers où ou d'avoir une bonne
relation avec tous les acteurs de cette
société on peut pas avancer
d'après des solutions alors le thème des
violences urbaines est en tout cas
présent aussi au cinéma vous souvenez
forcément de ce film la haine réalisé
par mathieu kassovitz est tournée
justement au quartier de la noé à
chanteloup-les-vignes justement là où a
été incendiée le chapiteau ce mercredi
20 novembre c'est les misérables qui
sort au cinéma prix du jury au dernier
festival de cannes et il sera
représentant de la france aux oscars le
film suit le quotidien d'une équipe de
la pac à montfermeil
il parle des tensions entre jeunes et
policiers tension notamment suite à une
interpellation qui dérape en bavure en
ce n'est pas un film anti flics pour
autant a assuré le réalisateur la dgi
sur le plateau de clichy écoutez je
démens les misérables séné un film anti
flic n'est un film en tout cas j'essaie
d'être le plus juste possible et de
parler d'une situation qui est
dramatique aujourd'hui donc les
policiers bien sûr je vais bosser à leur
place c'est pas évident après après je
suis pas là les protégés non plus et en
a qui font bien leur travail en a
d'autres qui ne font moins bien et en a
qui commettent des exactions mais est ce
que mon film raconte c'est que tous ces
gens que ce soit les habitants les
policiers vivent dans cette misère là
une réaction juin au cap sur ce qui a
été dit ladj ly parle de certaines
exactions on parle souvent des bavures
certaines ont été filmées des bavures de
policiers et écoutez moi j'ai pas vu le
film je sais pas de quel bord il peut
parler nous sur le département
les collègues sont formés il n'y a pas
eu d'incidents en marge des violences
urbaines d'ailleurs on peut souligner le
professionnalisme de mes collègues
comment sur les violences urbaines qui
ont su maîtriser rapidement des
individus interpellés des individus un
bon jeu là je vois pas de quoi
de quel événement il peut parler c'est
un peu caricatural bavure policière je
crois dans la fin des années 2000
c'était pas sur le territoire des
yvelines c'était dans son département de
seine-saint-denis
mais ça ça je ne sais pas de quoi on
essayait montre aussi le quotidien des
policiers dans les quartiers
voilà sûr c'est que c'est pas évident il
ya le celui qui les habite aussi dans
des logements hlm la situation est
difficile pourrait vous parliez tout à
l'heure de manque de moyens c'est c'est
la réalité aujourd'hui
oui alors il faut savoir que mes
collègues par exemple prenant les
événements qui lui a à mantes-la-jolie
un jour on va l'illustré comme ça moi
mes collègues sont la cible de tirs de
mortiers de feux d'artifice
on a nos collègues qui a été brûlé
gravement à la cuisse il manque on a ça
faisait des mois que l'on réclamait
détenus non feu on a vu les événements
de viry-châtillon des collègues ont été
brûlés au cocktail molotov
nous on réclame par exemple que mes
collègues soient équipés de tenues
justement pour faire face à 7,7 nouveau
type de violence parce que c'est ses
nouveaux seins ce phénomène de l'usagé
les feux d'artifice patrouiller dans ces
secteurs là il vous faut des des
véhicules adaptés un d un nombre
d'effectifs conséquence et en moyens
matériels avant tout oui alors matériel
mais surtout humain il faut savoir que
le département était victime d'une
restructuration il ya quelques années on
est passé de 2,9 commissariat neuf
agglomérations de nombreux postes ont
été supprimés
et donc quand vous avez affaire à de
tels événements forcément c'est très
difficile de faire avec les moyens que
vous avez face à des individus qui sont
de plus en plus violents et je pense que
malheureusement il ya un phénomène aussi
de 2
de banalisation de ces actes là vous
parliez des réseaux sociaux est ce que
s'annonce une compétition à celui qui
s'est le plus spectaculaire je sais pas
ça c'est dramatique par contre l'exemple
du 4/3 puisque mohamed à camille est en
plateau qui est a été en tout cas retenu
par le gouvernement comme un quartier de
la reconquête républicaine avec ce
dispositif de la police de sécurité du
quotidien ça c'est pas une réponse à la
hauteur en tout cas on n'a pas encore
assez de recul ou on est premier
retournement plutôt bien perçu c'est une
c'est une unité particulière qui
justement a pour mission de tous les
jours d'aller au contact des commerçants
des citoyens de faire des patrouilles
pédestres de faire un peu de justement
police de proximité ce qui était fait
dans au début des années 2000 par contre
ça coûte énormément en effectif et pour
mettre en place ce dispositif va
d'ailleurs chanteloup-les-vignes
l'agglomération de de conflent à part
par exemple voyez donc si tu es un
dispositif pour l'instant très limité on
n'a pas vraiment encore de recul et on
la seule chose c'est qu'on voit que ça
coûte énormément en effectifs ont parlé
du manque de moyens pourtant un plus de
75 milliards d'euros ont été dépensés
dans le cadre et de la politique de la
ville en 25 ans dont une grosse partie
dans la rénovation urbaine mohamed
khamis et ce cas votre avis ces moyens
qui sont comme conséquent plus de 75
milliards d'euros et ce qu'ils ont été
mal utilisé à votre avis alors si je
peux me permet de revenir à les suivre
sur le débat n'a van sant sur le sujet
alors effectivement si on met on dit
toujours qu'il manque de moyens
effectivement on manquera toujours de
moyens la police aujourd'hui un manque
d'effectifs mais c'est c'est le chat qui
se mord la queue en réalité si la police
réclament toujours plus de deux mobiles
de de moyens de voitures d'équipement
etc
mais derrière la violence elle augmente
donc c'est le cercle la violence et
continue d'augmenter on voit il ya dix
quinze ans la violence n'était pas la
même les jeunes 12 13 ans il était
respectueux aujourd'hui laissé les 12 13
ans qui jettent des cailloux parfois la
police donc la violence elle va
continuer à augmenter
on sait pas à chaque fois que la
violence augmente il faut ré équiper la
police équipe donner les moyens ni les
moyens c'est pas qu'une seule finale de
solutions justement
les culés les qr se disposer de la
reconquête république et de la
régularité reconquête républicaine est
un bon dispositif aujourd'hui on va
l'utiliser mais il faut qu'il soit
associé à d'autres dispositifs ou à
d'autres moyens
les associations les habitants eux mêmes
et c'est que je sens la rénovation
urbaine dont plus de 75 milliards
d'euros dans la rénovation urbaine c'est
à dire casser des barres d'immeubles
repenser l'aménagement ça ne résout pas
tous les problèmes ça ne résout pas tous
les problèmes mais je le disais pendant
plusieurs années déjà c'est repeindre
les bâtiments offert des trottoirs neufs
vous mettre des petits arbres ça
fonctionne pas ça fonctionne c'est bien
c'est une réussite en termes
urbanistique mais en terme social ça
n'avance pas ça résout pas les problèmes
sociaux du quartier et la rénovation
urbaine un objectif premier c'est quand
même que les habitants se sentent bien
et vivent mieux chez eux parce que les
services publics aussi tendance à fuir
ses quartiers ce qu'ils ne sont plus
dans les quartiers aujourd'hui de ses
services publics bah il ya eu un moment
donné une désertion de ses services
publics mais là on repart un petit peu à
l'inversé dire qu'on essaye de
réimplanter des serbes du service public
dans ces quartiers
mais c'est un tout c'est pas juste on
réimplante on remet la police on donne
des moyens c'est exactement ce que je
dis à chaque fois si tout le monde n'est
pas autour de la table pour discuter
d'un phénomène d'un problème et tout le
monde met la main à la pâte
ça n'avancera pas chacun voilà qui doit
passer par un dialogue c'est une
solution et une normale-5 des milliards
et des milliards ça n'avancera pas tant
que tout le monde ait pas autour de la
table un objectif commun ça passe par le
comment expliquer que cette situation ne
s'améliore pas le sociologue fabien
jobard adresse quelques pistes de
réponse soit ça veut dire qu' il n'y a
pas eu de politique forte soit ça veut
dire que les problèmes sont plus
profonds soit ça veut dire qu'on agit
sur un certain nombre de choses mais
qu'on laisse d'autres choses de côté en
gros dans les années 2000 la politique a
consisté à agir sur le bâti on a détruit
des immeubles et des tours et on a
essayé de disséminer reconstruire un peu
partout ailleurs mais c'est une
politique qui s'attaque pas à deux
éléments fondamentaux du problème le
premier c'est que les jeunes hommes sans
qualification qui sortent du système
scolaire
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas d'emploi pour
eux il n'y a plus d'industrie en france
et donc vous avez toujours une
population masculine à
qui se trouve disponible à l'oise yves t
le
la délinquance l'affrontement avec la
police l'autre explication ne l'écoutera
pas fabien jobard parler du manque de
moyens au travers de la police au
terrain on en a déjà parlé sur la
question du chômage 2 7 fois plus de
personnes sont sans emploi dans les
quartiers dits prioritaires par rapport
à voilà au reste de la france c'est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ce constat
est ce que le principal problème c'est
d'abord le chômage
mais bien sûr quelqu'un qui travaille
qui sème le matin il a une occupation
il va pas se dire je vais taper sur la
police je vais faire je vais préparer un
des cas un guet-apens chez le brut pour
le pomper ival matin il nourrit sa
famille il va se marier va se faire des
enfants et puis la machine va partir la
machine sociale en tout cas là il est
bloqué qui les 15 ans qui les quarante
ans il est en bas de l'immeuble
je lui demande si vous êtes d'accord ce
que le chômage c'est en tout cas l'un
des gros problèmes aussi dans ces
quartiers je pense que ça doit favoriser
un malheureusement il ya aussi cet
élément qui est présent dans certains
secteurs c'est le trafic de stupéfiants
c'est des individus on ne peut plus
établir le dialogue avec ces gens là
c'est des gens que l'on que la présence
policière va déranger donc du couple là
que le chômage conduit ces personnes à
des revenus est licite
on va dire forcément la drogue amène des
revenus conséquents et je pense que de
trouver un emploi fab le mans rémunéré
est ce que ces individus font vite le
choix est ce que justement mettre un
rentrer dans le trafic de stupéfiants
forcément la police est un élément voilà
qui va devenir forcément perturbé tout
ça après par contre pour produite et
contre le trafic de stupéfiants il faut
savoir que ça coûte énormément
énormément de moyens d'aider véhicules
soum des véhicules d'aider des unités
spécialisées cdd heures incroyable qui
est ça mobilise énormément de collègues
et vous pouvez pas lutter contre le
trafic de stupéfiants actuellement dans
les yvelines
et justement sur le travail des
associations si je prends le cas de
chanteloup-les-vignes s'avérait que le
chapiteau a été incendiée est un le
chapiteau qui était gérée par une
association est ce que penser que ce
travail des associations ça peut gêner
au quotidien le trafic de stupéfiants et
ça peut gêner du coup et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya des symboles c'est comme un
symbole un compte
on continue la violence urbaine
généralement st on s'attaque à un
symbole de la république soit une école
commissariat comme c'est devenu
compliqué mais on s'attaque à une école
à la pause qu'on va s'attaquer à la
caserne des pompiers on va s'attaquer au
premier dispositif qui est là il savait
sans doute pas que c'était une
association qui gérait pensé que c'était
la ville parce que souvent ils
comprennent pas trop donc quand on
s'attaque au premier on brûle des écoles
c'était un enfant qui va à l'école c'est
ton petit frère et sa petite soeur qui
va à l'école mais tu brûles l'école d'un
moment donné c'est la bêtise humaine
dans les mers qui essaye de mettre en
place des actions avec les associations
dans quoi je parlais du cas de
chanteloup les vignes
je propose juste d'écouter la mer sur l'
incendie du chapiteau qui est selon elle
dramatique pour les enfants elle a été
interrogée par aurélie ronces écoutez
vous savez quand on voit ça on se dit
mais ça va transformer durablement la
vie des gamins c'est à dire qu'il va y
va ce n'est plus rien ne se passe et ça
c'est pas possible
donc il faut aussi qu'on mette la
population et des enfants dans un avenir
des enfants besoin d'adultes qui eux en
qui ils ont confiance parce que c'est ça
aussi commencé à devenir un grand et un
citoyen donc dit bon on va leur montrer
qu'on est des adultes en qui on peut
avoir confiance
mais quand on prie justement les maires
et les associations d'actions de terrain
comme ça au prêt auprès des jeunes ce
que c'est dramatique est ce que vous ne
pensez aussi bien sûr mais tout comme la
question du chômage la question du
chômage on n'attend pas que le jeune ou
legrand jeunes soient au chômage monte
trouver une solution comment se fait-il
qu'il arrivait au chômage comment se
fait-il que les dispositifs qui sont
périscolaire ne sont pas assez
importants commencer comment se fait-il
que dans le quartier on a un échec
scolaire
comment se fait-il que dans le quartier
il ya la désertion de l'école on y vante
eu à l'école c'est pas normal
donc on s'attaque 1 à la fin du parcours
c'est quand il au chômage on n'a pas
regardé qu'est ce qu'il a fait avant le
chômage
à un moment donné s'il finit son sa
scolarité normalement et il part en
formation professionnelle où il continue
ses études logiquement il devrait
trouver du travail
attrapant la 5 zones industrielles et
zones d'activités comment se fait-il
qu'on a autant de chômeurs à trappes que
dans les autres villes leurs portails et
des populations qui viennent travailler
à trappes
à un moment donné il ya un problème le
monde associatif il un rôle important à
jouer sur wii vous parliez des
dispositifs de la pièce coup les
différences dire voilà intervenant sur
la vie d'une commune se communique que
se réunisse parle de trouver des
solutions
bon là nous le seul à la seule chose
qu'on peut dire sur les événements de
nos chantres living c'est que deux
individus ont été interpellés justement
suite à ces violences urbaines qui a une
réponse judiciaire que les deux
individus ont été écroués et qu' il faut
également aussi une réponse pénale à ces
événements faut que les que ces
individus ces délinquants et peur de la
justice ait peur des condamnations et là
une enquête est en cours en la sûreté
département de sûreté départementale
donc à investir sur le sur les
événements de chantoux lévis et nous on
attend également que les que ces
délinquants parce qu'on peut pas parler
de jeunes et c'est à nous c'est des
délinquants il faut qu'ils aient peur de
des conséquences et qu' il soit condamné
pour demande pour ce genre de choses on
a vu se développer des actions des toits
y âge de quartier notamment dans le
cadre du challenge m'a cité va briller
la coupe d'afrique des nations des
quartiers et qui attiré 3000 supporters
à mantes-la-jolie cet été avec
l'association des présidents de comités
de quartier à trappes nous avons
organisé un mois m camille un tournoi de
football inter katia quartier ce genre
d'action il est nécessaire pour apaiser
les tensions ou justement c'est un début
effectivement c'est un début parce qu'on
s'est aperçu qu'en fait
les différents city stade du quartier
ont permis la ghettoïsation des jeunes
c'est à dire qu'ils vont tuer d'un
quartier d'à côté pour jouer au foot par
exemple pourtant c'est banal en est
justement d' et certains quartiers se
sont approprié le city stade et ne
laissez pas les jeunes du quartier d'à
côté
pourtant qu'il ya une centaine de mètres
venir pratiquer dans ceux-ci styliste ce
city stade
donc nous l'objectif était de rouvrir ce
city stade cet espace public et se dire
que tout le monde est capable en tout
cas et autorisés à aller dans n'importe
quel autre city stade de la ville il n'y
aura pas de rivalité et c'est le message
qu'ont voulu faire passer aux jeunes
c'est que tout le monde peut venir jouer
au contraire il ya plus de deux
rivalités dans le foot dans le dans le
nord dans le défi de qui va être le
meilleur mais pas dans non c'est mon
city stade tu viens pas chez moi et
c'était l'un des objectif c'était de
réouvrir les quartiers et qu'ils
puissent au moins qu'ils puissent se
rencontrer autrement qu'à l'école alors
un autre jour d'action si on arrive déjà
à fin de cette émission pour approcher
les jeunes et policiers et le pro crêtes
qui se déroule en france des policiers
sur leurs temps libres qui vont à la
rencontre des jeunes ça c'est ça peut
être aussi un type d'action intéressant
pour rapprocher les jeunes et les
policiers de casser quelques stéréotypes
qu'on a de part et d'autre oui c'est des
bonnes choses c'est d'ailleurs c'est
bien si des collègues le font nous le
dispositif a été abandonnée depuis des
années sur le département s'étaient
laissés dlj s'était fait durant les
vacances scolaires des jeunes étaient
avait des activités encadrées par des
fonctionnaires c'est un dispositif qui
n'existe plus après ce que ça avait une
véritable impact sur la relation police
jeunes forcément après on en revient au
même
c'est toujours un problème d'effectif là
où on parle monde des sommes d'argent
qu'ils soient injectés vous parliez de
75 milliards d'euros injectés dans les
quartiers difficiles
nous on peut déplorer par contre que
l'état des commissariats et que les
bâtiments publics sont laissés à
l'abandon par par la préfecture et on
manque de moyens on a des commissariats
qui n'ont pas de douche et pas de
toilettes s'est fait pas de chauffage on
a eu encore le cas la semaine dernière
d'un commissariat sans le chauffage
il faudrait aussi penser un peu aux
commissariats quand il ya de l'argent
c'est toujours bien investir dans le
dans l'urbain mais ce serait aussi bien
de penser au commissariat eh bien merci
messieurs d'être passé en plateau pour
parler de ce sujet merci pour vos
réponses et votre éclairage voilà c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi rendez vous le mois
prochain pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8
débat belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]